over the last couple of weeks you might
have seen photos like this
flooding your social media feed these
are the snapshots from burning man which
if you don't know is the notorious Mega
cultural event held in the desert of
Nevada which they call Black Rock City
they build stuff they burn stuff and
over the time span of nine days these
group of people live together and they
function together around the 10 core
principles of radical inclusion gifting
decommodification radical self-reliance
radical self-expression communal effort
civic responsibility leaving no Trace
participation and immediacy a portion of
this video is sponsored by soundcore
more on them later in this video it
started in 1986 with just 20 people but
it's been growing by the thousands every
single year and this year it held about
80 000 people but throughout burning
man's history there's been multiple
accidents deaths arrests as well as some
really horrific stories of sexual
assault and in spite of their principle
of radical inclusion the desert
environment doesn't really seem exactly
like the most hospitable place for
people with mobility issues some of the
installations seem to not meet any kind
of safety regulation and in fact
throughout its history there's been
constant run-ins with law enforcement
and the Bureau of Land Management and
with this type of massive growth every
year they've been constantly dealing
with functional concerns traffic safety
concerns problems with scale and
accessibility so how has this event
continued on for so long and why is it
growing so fast and how did it go from
this
to this
what's up guys my name is dammy and I am
an architect in beautiful Vancouver VC
and when I started looking at the
history of burning man I was actually
really shocked and I think it's a really
fascinating case study from a design and
urban planning point of view this place
has no water no vegetation and the
temperatures they get up to 100 degrees
Fahrenheit and they drop to freezing at
night and they have wind storms that
kind of cover everything in dust and
despite all of that every summer these
group of people assemble a small City
and after nine days they disassemble it
and they leave zero trace of any human
presence I think Burning Man is a really
interesting example of how constrained
whether it's legal or functional or
site-specific how these constraints have
shaped a city into something that's so
successful in fact the very first plan
of burn learning man was developed in
1992 for a population of just 600 just
to satisfy the permitting requirements
in 1996 with a population of 8 000 the
added avenues for the very first time
and a second Circle and in order to
preserve the view of the burning man
they created a Zone called No Man's Land
lined on either sides with theme camps
and which were and to this day are kind
of the heart of Burning Man it can be
anything from Services entertainment or
other interactive experiences organized
by the people for the people as gifts to
the community still with more growth
they were constantly having issues with
traffic chaos sprawl and every year they
were losing the intimacy of the original
camping Circle which led to accidents
and a sense of isolation and conflict
between people
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
shut up
here try this
what is this it's Sal chorus sleep A10
it's got enhanced noise blocking system
and it's got a massive Sound Library to
help you improve your sleep it's also
got a four point noise masking system
and it blocks out 35 decibels of noise
which is 15 decibels more than your
standard earbuds but I'm a side sleeper
no problem it's lightweight so it stays
in your ears very snuggly oh
ah check the link in the description for
a limited time offer whoa
in 1997 burning man took place in a
different location near Hualapai Valley
this is when they recruited Rod Garrett
who's a landscape architect by training
and he put together the plans and
documents to meet the regulations of the
county the permitting requirements if
force them to include roads and street
names and urban amenities and due to the
constraints of the site also in order to
condense everything within the property
line it naturally developed this Arc
that spread out laterally from the
center the year after in 1998 when they
returned to their home in Nevada they
kept a lot of the aspects from their
experiment in 1997. they decided to form
the city into a concentric circle around
a geographic center where you could see
the men just conceptually I really love
this idea of a moving City like it's a
city that morphed itself to meet the
constraints of this new site and it
learn from its conditions and then when
it came back home it had become a better
version of itself by the early 2000s
Burning Man had grown to 25
000 people officially the size of a town
and I think here you can see one of the
most understated and fascinating things
about the evolution of Black Rock City
so this was the point where a lot of the
problems really started to get Amplified
there were staff disruptions and
Splinter groups and safety concerns and
the planners of BlackRock City
identified that a lot of these problems
can be traced back to alienation leading
to the loss of human connection so they
decided to ban vehicles except for the
approved art Vehicles they tried to make
the settlement a little bit more
walkable and the proposal to the plan
was to instead of having this thick band
of theme camps and the prime inside ring
of the city that these camps will be
distributed throughout the plan this
meant that they had to break down these
monolithic sections and when they did
find some success with the strategy they
started interjecting more and more of
these theme camps into the rest of the
site year after year but of course it's
when you start getting these mixed-use
scenarios where you start to have more
obvious issues for example having like a
dance party theme Camp next to like a
quiet relaxation Zone that could be
problematic and that's actually why so
many cities are zoned with very distinct
uses this requires a lot more granular
planning from everyone involved so Rod
Garrett he started implementing zoning
to separate the potentially clashing
uses and months before the event people
have to submit the plans for their camps
for approval there is fairly strict
guidelines it seems like for the design
of these camps with like dimensions and
potentially conflicting uses as well as
pretty much for everything else but can
this really solve the problem of safety
and accessibility throughout burning
man's history there's been numerous
deaths and near fatal accidents there's
open fires there's art vehicles and the
art installations are climbable and of
course you can't compare Burning Man to
a real City you know people only come
here for nine days and after that they
go back to the safety and Comforts of
their own homes and none of these are
like real permanent structures but just
to put things in perspective the safety
regulations of the building code is so
so so so so strict that for example
something that I just came across the
other day with my project is let's say
we have an existing building right and a
fire exit this way and a fire exit this
way and a path this way and this is like
a grassy area and so we decided to put
Windows right here to give a little bit
more Daylight into this admin space but
the city wanted us to put water curtains
which are kind of like sprinklers above
these windows and they wanted A New Path
here because in case there's a fire we
have to assume that people are going to
come out of the building and they're
going to be like oh my God where do I go
I must follow this path but there is
only one path
and we have to assume that they're
either gonna go this way or this way and
if they go this way there's like a
massive Raging Fire that's gonna shoot
out this window and people are gonna get
hurt but in reality and in common sense
when people leave a burning building
they're gonna be walking out in all
directions and they're not gonna care
whether it's a pave path or if it's a
grassy area so this is like one of the
few examples but anyways what I'm trying
to say is the building code forces us to
put these safety precautions in place
that sometimes go a little bit beyond
common sense and they really Force us to
design for the most extreme scenarios
and every time they print a new building
code it's built upon the accidents or
like the lawsuits from the years before
but the point of all of this is to
provide a safe and Equitable place for
everyone you know no matter what your
physical or mental capacities are
because if you don't put in rules like
this you'll get designs like this
so doesn't this and this kind of go
against one of their core principles of
radical inclusion the weird thing is
even in probably one of the most
inhospitable conditions there's actually
quite a large community of people with
disabilities at burning man that
actually come back year after year they
have what's called a Mobility Camp since
2012 whose Camp motto is radical
inclusion through radical accessibility
and they have things like wheelchair
accessible camping power for medical
equipment they have volunteers and they
take out a tractor and like a 20-foot
accessible trailer rig out onto the
desert three or four times a day so that
people who can't bike or walk they can
still experience the art but they do
make it very clear on The Burning Man
website the reality of the conditions at
the event and they really stress that
you know even though there's a big
support network everyone you know no
matter what your physical capabilities
is expected to live by the principles of
participation and radical self-reliance
and I think weirdly enough that's one of
the reasons why they feel empowered and
accepted they're not just seen as
helpless or seen just for their
disabilities they're just another burner
that's what they call themselves that
use the art to express themselves solves
we talk about accessible design you have
to understand the needs of of people and
and focus first on function right
but once you get there once you
understand function how can we make it
feel good
how does it get Beyond reminding you
that you might have a need that's
different from someone else to just be
something that melts into the
environment and doesn't stick out like
something you might see in a hospital
that's Mayan ziv who's an advocate for
accessibility based in Toronto and I
think she really nailed it on the head I
mean first it needs to be functional and
it needs to be accessible but that's
kind of the bare minimum like once you
figure that out how can we create
environments that give everyone the same
quality of experience and the same
quality of life and when you start
looking at the environment from that
lens you're going to start to see a lot
of problems in a lot of standard design
practice and in a lot of like
award-winning Spaces by a lot of
award-winning Architects but also if
you're smart I think you'll also start
to see more opportunities in this if you
think architecture is stagnant this is
one of the ways we're going to get new
types of spaces and I think something
that all of us can do kind of on a daily
basis if you're going somewhere just try
to think if I was on a wheelchair like
how would I get here if I was visually
impaired how would I do that and by
understanding and recognizing that I
think we can develop more empathy and we
can have better and stronger communities
so where am I going with all of this as
an architect I do want to attribute the
success of Burning Man to the design
but it's not I think it's actually the
social strategy behind their design and
the urban plan this is a quote from
Larry Harvey who's one of the
co-founders of Burning Man he said we've
shown that you can actually deal with
the complexity of urban Problems by
using specifically cultural means the
citizens participate in creating the
city in fact half of our control is just
based on watching their behavior and
meeting their needs and that's the whole
history of the development of the city
so what is participation on one level
participation means that people should
interact with others and engage in the
activities and not be voyeuristic on a
deeper level participation means that
aside from the limited government that
handles like the basic infrastructure
and like Emergency Services the citizens
they co-create and they maintain the
city and essentially its Civic
engagement I think there's something
kind of magical that comes from the
process of building something together
when I interviewed Scott Kemp and some
other architects who work with
indigenous communities a lot of them
they don't see architecture or the
building as their end goal their goal is
to use the process of building as a way
to heal the communities and to bring
them together and in fact Scott went as
far as to say that he's not really the
one who designs the buildings like the
community designs them and he's just the
hand that draws what they design even if
you're contributing at a really small
level like gifting someone a cookie or
saying hi to your neighbors you are
participating in building the social
fabric of the city and if you don't like
something you can talk to someone in
normal cities there's just like so many
steps you have to to get through
bureaucracies and there's political
barriers and eventually people feel
pretty powerless in the end but in
essence I think it's the principle of
participation that's allowed Burning Man
to transform from this to this and I
think this is how they've been able to
continue growing through so many years
of conflict with the authorities I do
wonder if going to Burning Man actually
affects people's attitudes when they
leave the event and come back to their
normal lives but I mean I would kind of
assume that if you've had a really
positive experience somewhere it kind of
changes a little part of you right I
don't know I've never been to burning
man but I would kind of like to go it
sounds really cool let me know what you
think if you like this video remember to
like And subscribe and if you like this
video you might also like my other video
where I discuss a very different type of
settlement in the desert I'll leave the
link right here and with that I'll see
you in the next one
[Music]